[Music]
forest hills
an upper middle class enclave in the
heart of queens new york where more than
70 000 people live within two square
miles the neighborhood streets are busy
but pj's restaurant is empty
kiss me
prior to opening the restaurant joe and
madeline were living a dream life
when i first came to the states i
started working in construction work
with my brother pj
pj and i were very very close he really
truly taught me about life and being my
own man
busted my hump for 20 years
worked as hard as i could to get my wife
and kids nice things a nice house
we were going places
and then pj passed away
joe was a shell
joe was just empty
i can't mention his name without feeling
that hurt inside you know
he didn't really know how to walk
without that guy being around
he just meant everything to him
i just couldn't stand to see him in pain
and when this place came for rent i said
go and get the key and we'll we'll just
name it after pj
which is even more special because this
was the ball that pj owned
how you guys doing
you know what i know about running a
high-end steakhouse
apparently not much i don't know why
we're with a garden kind of honey
mustard joe
it's a honey mustard garlic roasted
salmon that's what it's supposed to be
on the menu really joe and madeline
they're from a construction background
so they didn't really know what it was
like to get into the restaurant industry
my steak just was just flavorless red
meat is red meat i don't know what you
would expect myself to do about that
it's a big problem and the food's
inconsistent
i'm a very good chef
people come here just for me how's
everything that's terrible i'm sorry
they love my food and and everything is
great
they didn't like the steak now i have to
avoid two chicks i want this place to
work so bad but we don't know what we're
doing wrong give me a cigarette right
now
give me a cigarette i suck almost two
million dollars in this restaurant i see
it dying in his shoes right now the two
insurances have to get paid this week
this restaurant it's cost us our savings
our house our cars everything four
thousand that was so much money
that's it i'm gonna drink it yeah
golden dragon you've been doing that all
day joe sits
and drink glasses of wine and watch
television when there is a million
things going wrong
here and he's just basically feeling
sorry
if the problems aren't addressed
we'll have no choice we'll have to close
the door
[Music]
pj steakhouse it looks great from the
outside there must be trouble on the
inside
wow place is beautiful unbelievable
wow anybody here
my goodness me no one at the front desk
[Music]
hello
so a customer or mr rowdy no i am the
owner you're the owner
ah
right how are you from how are you
pleasure to see you um
good to see you too didn't expect to see
you uh at the bar you've got no one at
the front desk there i see that yeah as
soon as chef ramsay showed up panic set
in and i started getting the butterflies
we're pretty slow this time of day so
slug
is that numb it is normal for lunch [ __ ]
right
hello it's my wife marlon hi
how are you good nice to see you too oh
eric eric good to see you good to see
you i'm not intimidated by gordon we're
here to get his job done and we better
do the job the best we can and if he can
help us great if he can't then we can go
[ __ ] himself
well first of all i'm happy to be here
um somewhat uh yeah taken back by
walking in and haven't seen how
beautiful this place is what's wrong
with it
i'm not uh
restaurant material i found out i'm a
contractor who uh jumped into this who
thought i'd get great managers good
floor people i'll sit back and have a
couple of wines at the bar and i wish
everything restaurants were that easy
yeah all right
you know i'm learning as i go
it can put you in a whole real fast
restaurant i don't know where to go okay
well i've just arrived yeah i'm starving
i'm gonna have some lunch and then we'll
talk after you
i want to cook them a great meal and i'm
gonna let them find other problems in
the restaurant besides mine because i
don't think mine's a problem
oh dear thank you okay come on
so stay cause
oh dear
no porterhouse no new york no rump
there's only two cuts of steak
two steaks on the menu in a steakhouse
should be minimum eight to ten how are
you welcome to pjs my name is colin well
thank you how are you doing great thank
you for joining us so i'll start with
crab cakes then maybe the shrimp and
roasted garlic ravioli and then i'll
have the filet minion with the uh
gonzalo demi glass all right i'll go put
this in for you thank you no problem
i know eric's a good chef so what's to
be nervous about
what do you order crab cakes plus filet
mignon with gorgonzola medium rare and a
shrimp ravioli write it down i just love
what i do this is perfect my food is
good and if he could takes it like i
seen him critique other people's food
i'm gonna probably throw it at him
what is that the crab cake somebody spit
on my plate boy is that on there that's
[ __ ] mango sauce oh [ __ ] mango thank
you
it's like something at the modern art
museum splat
okay
wow that's [ __ ] disgusting
it's rancid
[Music]
plastic bits of crap running through the
crab cakes is everything okay
the chef sent out a little surprise i
got bits of plastic running through
there see the plastic i don't know where
it came from but it's definitely there
but i'm done with that thanks okay
[Music]
severe warning
for what's to come
eric
you found a piece of plastic in there
where's that from
oh man [ __ ] him
i have no idea where that place came
from just happened to appear i don't
even have plans to get my kitchen
[Music]
the owners sat at the bar watching
television
and they wondering why they're not doing
well
hi
is that joe's seat there at the end yes
all the time he'll sit there most of the
night
oh
dear joe does need to get off his ass
and start paying attention
oh here's my food
fantastic let me leave you alone to eat
right melvin thank you
lovely thank you
[Music]
so
how'd you like the steak um
quite tough and they always said with
royals or yeah nah
thank you my pleasure uh you said the
beep's a little tough
there's nothing positive being said i
don't really suck that bad
you know
[Music]
go dear that
looks
like the biggest pile of [ __ ] ever to be
served in queens
my god
[Music]
the raviolis are disgusting
tart
tannin and
just a mouthful of acidic thick rich
creamy sauce that tastes like there's a
buzz in your mouth
it just seemed like chef ramsay didn't
like anything excuse me oh god
oh dear this is really bad i can really
start to understand
to why queens is running
as fast as it can from pjs
disgusted by the food in this beautiful
restaurant chef ramsay heads to the
problem area
the kitchen did you cook everything yeah
that was pretty [ __ ] embarrassing
[Music]
100 pissed me off
that jeffrey hemsey didn't enjoy my meal
what's with the coolies it's like
something at the modern art museum splat
where is that from when we can from
again disgusting
the steak fillet should melt in your
mouth and it did nothing of the sword
that's what we could afford
eric come around so i can talk to you
properly
i was shocked i really thought that
eric's food was a lot better than what
chef ramsay said it was
the food was [ __ ] i get a lot of
compliments really wow a lot of
compliments from where the place is
[ __ ] empty
who's running the place
for the most part i am oh please first
of all i'm here every day he's not here
every day i'm not here enough to mother
him but i am here he should be here but
he's not doing it if you're here really
overseeing everything then these
problems aren't going to be here so get
your ass off the ball stool and stand in
here and do it every single night can
you motivate yourself to want to keep
the restaurant open i don't know
but he's giving up
i see that myself here i've given up
guys i'm [ __ ] sorry but take one good
look at yourselves first if there's one
thing that has to change it's people's
attitude around here whether you like or
not you are russian terts you have the
[ __ ] responsibility of making this
place work
but there's too many people turning
their back on things that are wrong i
gotta get some fresh air
what a shame
we have absolutely no idea what we're
doing here
just a big disaster
after a miserable lunch gordon takes
time to sit down with the one person who
appears to have not given up joe's wife
madeline the word pj where does that
come from joe's brother joe's brother
joe's brother owned an irish bar
restaurant here 10 years ago and he died
when it was at its peak he died
how close were they
they were best friends and he was very
sad he was empty i was worried for his
welfare i was worried
and when this place came for rent he
came home and told me about it so i told
him you know get the key
and we'll put his brother's name back
over the door and he spent all the money
but uh it helped him
[Music]
it's getting to him now just the money
and i think that's why he's at that bar
having drinks because he's looking
around he is embarrassed
at how this turned out and how much did
he spend 1.2 million to build him
what does it need to take per week to
break even
about 17 to 18 000. what's it currently
running at now
four
for that four thousand dollars oh my
gosh
uh take me back joe was very successful
before he opened the yes restaurant yeah
in construction yes and and where were
you living at the time when it was
when we were successful yeah i had
designed a house it was incredible so
you designed your dream house yes
but we sold it you sold the house to
keep the business open yes we got rid of
everything to stay here
but this restaurant
did more for me than my house it it
brought my husband back
how do you
how do you walk away from that
i i can't
this is unbelievable well that's helped
me to understand the background
as much as it has caused us to to keep
this place opened
at the same time it gave us back
joe and
we just can't let it go
we'll do whatever we have to do to keep
this place going
[Music]
after his chat with madeline gordon has
a better understanding of what pj means
to this family
now he wants to learn more about how the
business operates and there's no better
way to do that than watching a dinner
service
hi good evening welcome to pj's thank
you can i take your coat
oh actually real comfortable you have to
leave it here
okay can't take these two
as is the case with many of the
restaurants that chef ramsay visits the
word has spread in the community and
pj's is much busier than normal
[Music]
i'm not used to being the hostess
how would you like that cooked
well done
ordering a salmon well i just know it's
good and i know it's been and i know i
can handle the job and i can do the job
really well cause my food is good how
are the stuffed mushrooms coming
talk to me for two seconds
he literally doesn't talk behind the
line he doesn't communicate with me
especially when it's busy the worst
situation in the [ __ ] world all right
yes sir i've got to talk to them come on
eric's lack of communication has the
staff waiting for direction and the
diners waiting for food
normally wait this long for entrees yes
yeah it usually takes two hours to eat
here from two hours two hours from start
to finish
[Music]
all
eric
they're starting to complain now that
there's no food out there
come on you can do better than this
can't you you give a [ __ ] yeah give a
[ __ ] come on then big man this is a
steakhouse yes pj steakhouse pga
steakhouse yeah pathetic joke that's
what it stands for
come on guys
nobody looks too happy here i know we
haven't been here
didn't get you dinner
for the amount of people we had tonight
it was a ridiculous amount of time they
had to wait for the food that's it i'm
going to drink it
[Music]
eric how long on that 16 putting it up
right now an hour into dinner service
food is finally leaving the kitchen
because of the amount of customers
everyone is delivering the food even
madeleine
who is clearly not comfortable with the
job
listen
let's go over this okay not a waitress
not a hostess
i only own it
so i know nothing about the food
i am probably the only person who owns a
restaurant in the world who wouldn't
know what good food is that's the truth
i i left that part up to joe from the
beginning give me a glass of shiraz
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service table 30. all the apps are in a
window many customers have received food
but for most it wasn't worth the wait
it's really gross you don't like it it
tastes like lemonade
lemonade
wow okay so i'll tell the chef about the
chicken
[Music]
can you take this off a tablespoon
why she didn't like it at all and what
do you want me to do with it
no i'm saying can we take it off i'll
have a word with them
i went to check the menu it's chicken
madeira
and i will have them take it off for you
well you didn't even recognize it
okay thank you
thank you
i just don't know
if i'd have better manners at the table
how long on 23 salmon and the fillet
that's someone's [ __ ] come on guys eric
touch the top of that salmon it's like a
bullet yeah it's too old for that it's
only gonna come back
chef ramsay is standing there and
catching the mistakes as they're
happening look at the crap underneath
there
look at that harry that's well done
everything just feels like it's turning
downward touched up there
yeah that's not medium it's a disaster
it was horrible to watch it just fall
apart come on no i can't
it's too much for me
with a restaurant full of unhappy
customers the chicken is chewing and a
kitchen falling apart look at that
that's well done
chef ramsay has seen enough of the
dinner service and heads to the storage
area to see what problems lie below sat
in there
[Music]
ah stuck to the cardboard box no one
gives a [ __ ] about look
oh
oh my god
look at that
oh
is that
[Music]
that just sums up the whole restaurant
fading away rotten
and just one big [ __ ] embarrassment
[Music]
chef ramsay knows that tonight's dinner
service was not lost on joe and madeline
thank you but he wants to make sure they
have a complete picture of the state of
the restaurant oh yeah yeah
this is so hard you know what
i've just come to the conclusion that no
one gives a [ __ ]
stay there
when chef ramsay walked in that box i
was terrified
this is the big kick in the bollocks
[Applause]
i'm not here for this
[Music]
we're using horrible plastic lemon juice
in a sauce that customer complained
about the fact that it tasted of lemon
we've got fresh lemons downstairs that
have gone rotten
i just can't believe it if it was me i'd
be down with
it with a toothbrush here's the killer
blow for me just that one there
dealing with the restaurant and the food
and the customers one thing but where
the [ __ ] do you start with that
it was beyond bad
it's such a lack of pride it's such a
lack of caring
[Music]
who knows what the [ __ ] goes on behind
her back i don't know
[Music]
it is your job to go in that walking box
and rotate your stock and clean it out
and it's part of our job to make sure he
does it
why should i have to [ __ ] worry about
this [ __ ]
was it your business
you can't stand there and be silent
anymore
you can't do that
it seems like the whole blame of this
whole place is coming down on my
shoulders and it's not all my fault
i'm not the [ __ ] problem here
we're slopping it out guys
just get a bag and throw it out
can't believe that [ __ ] can you
how in the name of god
imagine the waste of food
we're worse to blame joe i had no idea
what was in there i am very disappointed
with eric i realized tonight that a lot
of the problems in the kitchen is eric
definitely a change has to come
the bottom line is
nobody around here wants to work nobody
[Music]
undeterred by a rough day one chef
ramsay hits the streets of forest hills
armed with a camcorder to do some
grassroots research on what people
really think of pj steakhouse we got two
seconds sure pj's the steakhouse have
you heard of it have you been there i
have it was not a pleasant experience
when was the last visit to pjs six
months ago i boycotted it have you heard
of pj's yes describe the dinner slow
cold not too good wouldn't go back this
is incredible thank you so much
[Music]
after hearing what the neighborhood had
to say
jeff ramsey calls the owners and staff
to a local theater take a seat
we're in this movie theater and we have
absolutely no idea what we're doing
there this is a serious world premiere
and the movie's entitled pjs the word on
the street
oh gosh i don't have a good feeling
about this i'm scared to see what's
going to happen lights please
have you ever been to pjs tj's i've been
there quite often actually when was the
last visit to pjs six months ago i
boycotted it they never cooked the stick
right this is incredible the same [ __ ]
went on six months ago i saw last night
how was dinner atrocious pretty my son's
steak was hockey puck i actually
recognized two of the customers that was
on that tape and i said holy [ __ ]
i ordered salmon i got flounder that's
ridiculous how many people have you told
in the last six months not to go there
there's 66 apartments in my building and
you tell them all not to go yes
it's total [ __ ]
i wanted to turn around and smack eric
in the mouth
that's how angry he was he's behind us
munching on popcorn with britney's face
what was the food like awful really
everything was pretty horrible pretty
horrible yeah i think chewy not too
flavorful if you had the chance to
change what would it be better food
better food that is from the people on
the street and these people are going to
keep that place open my god
i was disgusted with the little movie
thing we just saw i don't believe it's
all that true you know it's not that bad
why do you find it funny
we're sat here in an embarrassing
situation it's definitely nothing to
laugh about eric i i don't know i don't
believe all of it
[Music]
it infuriates me if the food was good to
say it was excellent
we have got to start turn this around
can this restaurant survive where eric
run the kitchen
[Music]
devastated but informed by what they
heard at the theater the owners have a
clear picture of how pj's was perceived
by the town
but chef ramsay has more um there's one
big issue
eric there's nothing worse than having a
chef in the kitchen trying to produce
mediocre food
[Music]
i'm telling you the engine room is
[ __ ] and if that's not working
nothing's gonna work
this business cannot go any further
forward with a liability like that it's
just gone to a stage where he should
have been gone a long time ago
you realize you're both at fault
absolutely because you're accepting the
tolerating yes the incompetence and he's
taking advantage of your weakness by
becoming worse at what he's paid to do
i would like to give him our last chance
tonight i'm gonna put him on the spot
i'm gonna call it as i said get a grip
cook your ass off or game over for me
yeah sounds great
[Music]
tonight will be eric's last chance to
save his job so chef ramsay has made a
few menu changes to help the kitchen
keep up okay tonight we have to start
building our reputation up so we're
gonna offer a mix grill we got the
amazing size of chicken steak
beautifully done on the broiler a little
mini slider tomato roasted lamb sausage
sauteed mushrooms fries and onion rings
introducing a mixed grill to say thank
you to the neighborhood and welcome back
and and give us a shot such a brilliant
idea that is our special this evening i
know not one steakhouse this evening
anywhere in queens is serving a
beautiful mixed grill i love it you
don't get that anywhere that's great
eric anything on there you can't do
it you can do it all okay i need eric
madeline and joe two seconds please yes
this is what i do let me do what i do
okay eric one thing i need to see is the
timing the time it has to be absolutely
spot-on tonight's your nine you have to
show me that you have to [ __ ] show me
it's time for her to step up to the
plate tonight uh there's no room for him
here okay you're the owners who's
running it tonight i am what are you
doing tonight salads salad i don't want
to see you anywhere near the [ __ ] bar
run it run it run it run it
okay
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
hi how are you good evening welcome to
pjs today before yeah follow me we have
our grill for two tonight have fun
please smile a lot smile okay
enjoy
it's called our pj's mixed grill it has
a blank steak on it it has lamb sausage
comes with grilled chicken with that's
your flank steak right there would you
like to start out with one of those yeah
what can i get you tonight makes grill
special thank you
this is unbelievable already there's a
renewed energy going on and this mixed
grill has got them sort of excited but i
know it's early days however the big
pressure is on eric and madeline she has
to run a business and he has to be
consistent in the kitchen otherwise it's
[ __ ] history
this strip a half rack two full you got
us made it with much solid joe we gotta
rock tonight you ready bro it's nice to
see my husband off the bar stool on his
feet and back to work did you have an
order yeah well done excellent eric when
we start to send the mixed krill what i
don't want to do is see half the table
in the window without the other half
coming at the same time yes chef
excellent thank you it makes me feel
confident when i can hear chev's voice
behind me you know that yes chef joe i'm
ready for that tomato mozzarella
mademoiselle steak medium
slider just lettuce and tomato
i need to pick up over here pj's mixed
grill with joe and eric working together
food is leaving the kitchen at a good
pace
and now the first mix grill special is
hitting the table when the first mixed
grill started to go out you know you
could see people in the dining room
looking over and getting excited how's
everything right it's really cold
everything's cold this is cold and this
is cold i'm sorry about that
mushrooms are cold sausage is cold it's
supposed to be medium oh come on eric's
the first one it's the first [ __ ]
table
corn eric please yeah don't let me down
yes pick up on that pj's mixed grill
ordering a salmon we got a pj's mixed
real we got calamari first the mix grill
special is extremely popular with 21
orders already taken i need to pick up
over here table 12. the kitchen has
pushed out 14 of them in a hurry
now it's time to find out if chef
ramsay's dish cooked by eric is
satisfying the customers
[Music]
how's everything i mean that's terrible
i'm sorry it's freezing cold and it was
raw there's some pinkishness in the
chicken i will be right back okay
is everything okay it's ice cold and all
right i'm very sorry about that i'll
take it right back can he change that
for like
something
everything's coming back ah i'm so
[ __ ] lost man he hates it oh come on
this is getting worse than last night
eric couldn't cook a sausage it was
sad
what's going on here guys there's one
simple [ __ ] dish on there to make
things look somewhat easier yeah real
[ __ ] simple
i've never ever ever ever seen it this
fact i don't carry anything let's stop
the madness stop
it door close the [ __ ] door
it's an hour into dinner service and
with food coming back at a ridiculous
rate he hates it oh come on and eric
completely giving up i don't care
jeff ramsey knows he is left with just
one choice let's stop the madness stop
it close the [ __ ] door
close the [ __ ] door
[Music]
close the [ __ ] door
[Music]
it was his last shot and he didn't
perform it's a serious problem
[Music]
no lie our chef walked out there
shutting down the kitchen
after shutting down dinner service chef
ramsay calls an emergency meeting with
the owners
you cannot continue like this i'm trying
my best
and i cannot work with no tools in there
he's a cook but he's not a chef there's
a lot of money invested here and if i
have to choose between a future
and a chef i have to choose the business
he needs to go we need a new kitchen
leader
it was a no-brainer please
give me a real chef
i am willing to bring a chef in here and
pay personally for that chef to help
turn this business around for the first
month but that's your decision you can't
ask for more than that
you're the owners and it's your call
it's in the morning
we had to make a quick decision we
couldn't let a linger on we had to rip
the band-aid off you know
come
outside this point in time if i don't do
something
it's not going to be here at all
i can't lose a million dollars
you know what i think it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we should go whatever direction we have
to go in
what you gotta do
so i can tell you do what you gotta do
we gotta move on my friend
if my shit's not good enough let him
find somebody else cause i'm [ __ ]
done with it
[Music]
it's time for a 360 you know
getting rid of eric
it was tough
but what's best for the restaurant is
the way i'm gonna go
he's not the only thing that has to
change here
he definitely is not the only thing
i need to get back on my feet and start
paying attention to the business and joe
does also it's got to be becoming about
keeping this place open and money
joe and i need to keep this place going
give it a golden opportunity
[Music]
with chef eric now out of the picture
chef ramsay is ready to present his plan
for the new pjs
how are you feeling great it's been a
tough week yes time to put all that
aside this is not just a new chapter
this is a new book are you ready
yes
the steakhouse has closed
pj's grill is now
open look at that
that's beautiful
inviting some just rich is clear pj's
grill
i think it's a wonderful idea i think
it's perfect for the neighborhood right
should we go inside
yeah yes
let's go
the important part of keeping pjs
absolutely crucial oh my god joe
this
era here is dedicated to him
now it has a proper meaning
and more importantly what a lovely
tribute
[Music]
it's beautiful
[Music]
it
brought a tear to my eye you know
it's a good reminder of why this place
is called pjs
i feel pg's presence here today
thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
madeline joe two seconds
want to introduce you to your new chef
this is mark mark elliott madeline the
owner lovely to meet you i'm joe the
owner i'm really excited to be here oh
we're excited to have you like westbrook
i'm just so excited i just can't wait to
taste his food i just can't wait to see
the reaction of the customers he knows
he's food inside out and he knows how to
cook let me tell you that yeah it's long
story i'll explain later
just having someone new and
professional with ideas in this
restaurant it'll motivate and turn
things
around with joe and madeline embracing
chef ramsay's plan right
he now introduces the new menu for pj's
grill time for some dramatic change
with the food i'm excited about this
part this is the bit that really gets me
fired up quick run through the menu yes
small fresh casual and more importantly
fast irish jew
chickens calipini classic okay stay free
we're a grill so we've got the most
amazing grill the most amazing steak
fred okay happy good maddling i need two
seconds with you please yeah come with
me darling good
excellent
[Music]
there's one
last change what i need to see from you
tonight more than anything is just warm
with the customers i want the burden off
your shoulders tonight and the only way
around that okay
was to bring in someone very special
i'll use someone i trust with my
restaurant this man handles 250 staff a
day and he's here tonight to help you
say hello aaron
how are you how are you sir good when
you're worried about what's going to
happen next or what to say next or how
to handle that situation there's your
buffer don't be scared to ask questions
and get out there with it okay all right
chef ramsay loans his manager to train
me is this unbelievable i only hope we
perform what the faith is giving us you
know otherwise that's the end of it
[Music]
it's the big night and this restaurant
has been transformed in 24 hours from a
steakhouse to a neighborhood grill
even though chef ramsay has brought in a
new chef okay yeah we chef feeling good
and his own manager okay are we all sad
pj's fate still rests with madeline and
joe you know it's a fantastic face and
they come in a nice smile just make sure
we keep them talking don't leave them
kind of standing there staring at you
this is a huge night for pjs because
people are coming back here for the
first time they're going to sit down to
hopefully a new madeline and joe we need
this launch to go well
otherwise you know we'll have no choice
we'll have to close the door
[Music]
oh good evening welcome to pjs how you
guys doing delighted to have you with us
okay enjoy your evening
30 minutes into dinner service a
surprise guest from the past shows up hi
good evening how are you welcome to pjs
i know you do i do
when was the last visit to pjs six
months ago i boycotted it they never
cooked the steak right the service
terrible if you have any problems please
ask the madeline right away madeline i
was shocked that he's back for a
surprise visit and i hope
that we won't disappoint him enjoy
please
this guy a lot of negative feedback
about the restaurant the young couple
that just walked in is it
yes
make sure gordon and the chef know
[Music]
table ten people i'd have eaten here
before they were in your film yeah
actually so previous customers they
complained last time they were here so
watch that ticket yeah yeah let's go
well
hi how are you i'm probably going to
recommend the mixed grill does look kind
of interesting we're going to try the uh
mixed grill great thank you all right
first order stuffed mushrooms house
salad house salad three a mixed grill
that's gonna be the hit tonight kids
so they're two different temperatures on
one mixed drill yeah i'm gonna cut the
steak in half and lead have to be in
there a little bit longer i love that
flexibility music to my [ __ ] ears
thank you so much you're welcome how are
we doing guys we're good how's that stew
good you guys have to get this next time
with the kitchen functioning in a
cohesive and professional manner
[Music]
madeline
madeline is about to get her first of
many lessons in proper management
what's wrong with this guy
ridiculous cut it out
don't go
please don't go anywhere i'll be right
back
that's it that's your last break i
didn't get the break
i never left okay go chase your waiters
let's find out come on and it was
following me
everywhere we need to go find our
kitchen what we have what we don't have
there's no hood there let's get back in
let's check on this table four
i didn't realize how many places you had
to be okay where are we going now
where's going
how was everything guys that was fun
very good dinner service is off to a
strong start i'm going to find out
what's happening with table 10. but the
former customers
whose opinion signifies whether peaches
has really changed did you eat anything
yet
has yet to be served
you haven't been fed yet
i'll be right back before this critical
customer walks out the door madeleine
must get her kitchen under control table
ten you haven't been fed yet dick that
actually went to table nine [ __ ] you now
who's sending food to the wrong tables
guys take care of me thank you
oh jesus christ the moment
we're just a little behind right now
okay chef
they're starving so they need something
and they need it now thank you mark
let's go
please take a breath take the pressure
off don't worry working hard give me two
minutes
you okay beautiful baby flank steak a
slider grilled chicken
that's beautiful yes come on pick up mix
girl window
let's not take this to the wrong table a
second time please really well handled
with it really well handled in the
kitchen thank you
[Music]
hi how are you how's everything
it's really good now i think it's gonna
be great
thank you they're happy with the new
menu they're happy with the food he said
he was definitely coming back oh it
makes me feel so good
so good so please enjoy your dinner
[Music]
everyone loves everything man hey you
know what it's all for you joe
you're a different person when you have
confidence in your chef everybody is
rocking and rolling nice job across the
board i was actually very proud to be uh
owner of pj's grill
[Music]
chef ramsay's vision of pj's grill was
realized how'd you feel
great it was a team effort that was led
by the new chef madeleine and joe
tonight
pj's grill served 90 customers who love
the food and more importantly are coming
back
because they've had a great time
the difference just with a decent chef
in the kitchen doing his job that he's
paid to do
what a weight off your shoulders
but the most important thing is i saw
two owners who were passionate happy and
dealing with their business
what chef ramsay's done here is
incredible i don't really know how he
knew how to go to the heart of joe
but he did it's just been unreal it's
like i just got a fire back you know
i haven't felt that way a long time
this is the first time in
a lot of years
i feel my brother's looking down on me
you know
look over my shoulder
you can do it
thank you so much
thank you good night
during my stay here it's been dark rainy
and gloomy and i'm not just talking
about the weather but based on what i
saw tonight in this restaurant i
seriously hope that tomorrow the sun
shines on pj's grill and into the future
because it deserves it
[Music]
after chef ramsay left pj's business did
improve but after a great deal of
thought joe and madeline made the most
difficult business decision of their
life they decided to close pj's grill
and return to the construction business
[Music]
you